die ergebnisse müssen wir abwarten es
sind ja noch wichtige staaten in der
auszählung trump hat wichtigen swing
state florida geworden ohne florida
hätte er die wahl nicht gewinnen können
und jetzt klappt es einfach abzuwarten
bis alle stimmen ausgezählt sind erstmal
ist trump einer der präsidenten der kein
krieg angefangen hat das muss man mal
festhalten
ich finde auch das mediale bild von
trump völlig überzeichnet da
unterscheiden sich die deutsche medien
auch nicht vor den amerikanischen außer
fox news
und er hat ergebnisse geliefert also er
hat das establishment aufgebrochen
das war sein wahlversprechen und er hat
seine wahlversprechen eingehalten und
diskutieren auch die wähler und das
problem ist medial als auch bei der
demoskopie das haben wir bei clinton
schon gesehen dass trump unterschätzt
wurde trump wurde jetzt auch
unterschätzt
wir haben voraussagen gesehen die ihm zu
98 prozent bescheinigt haben dass er
nicht wiedergewählt wird diese vor
aussagen waren falsch
und jetzt müssen wir einfach abwarten
tram hat eine ganz feste wählerbasis die
immer unterschätzt wurde
und dann muss man einfach wenn die
stimmen ausgezählt sind über die bücher
gehen denn wir sehen hier ein
kopf-an-kopf-rennen mit beiden dessen
korruptionsskandale über seinen sohn nie
medial aufgearbeitet wurden und das ist
der eigentliche skandal die deutsche
außenpolitik ist nicht durch konsistenz
geprägt wir haben es uns mit
hauptpartnern verscherzt mit den usa mit
china mit europäischen partnern
und das ist ganz allein der
bundeskanzlerin und dem in meiner so aus
meiner sicht völlig inkompetente heiko
maas unserem außenminister zu verdanken